MALE SPEAKER: So this
is a little different
because it's less about
the technology itself
and more about the process
and the community, and how
we work together to
produce new standards.
So I think it's a nice way of
tying together all the stuff
that we've talked about already.
So to moderate this session
we have Lyza Gardner
from [INAUDIBLE],
and take it away.
LYZA GARDNER: Sure, great.
So I think that you just kind of
stole what I was going to say,
which was pretty much that
this is a great session
to end the day on.
I think it pulls together
a lot of the threads
that we've been
talking about all day,
and I think that there will be
some fun discussion about all
the standards' fun.
So to start us
off today, Brian's
going to give us a little bit
of an introductory context.
He's with the
Apollo Group and is
co-author of the extensible
web manifesto, about which we
will be speaking today.
He's also the chair of the W3C
community group on the same.
Member of many things.
Expert, I'm sure, of many
of those things, as well.
Take it away.
BRIAN KARDELL: OK, so I'm
going to talk about evolution
committees and revolutions.
In case you know me online--
some people have trouble,
they say I don't look like
that-- so this is who I am.
Say hi to me.
So I work for the front-end
platform team at the Apollo
Education Group, and we do
online education-- higher ed--
at a pretty large
scale for education.
And in my personal
life I'm involved
in these things on the top here.
So there's this
big cross-section
for me-- has me thinking
really a lot about standards.
And so I was just going to
throw us way back for brief.
Our concept of standards really
comes from industrialization.
Suddenly we grew amazing
complexity and scale,
and we realized
pretty quickly-- like,
snap-- this is really hard.
We don't really
know how to do this,
and actually we still don't
really know how to do it.
But this is the beginning
of professional engineers,
and these engineering
associations started
and engineers went, "We need
some controls around the stuff.
We need standards."
And so they started, and
they created these standards.
And they were regional
and incompatible,
and they found out
some valuable lessons,
like technically great ideas
that you can't actually
get implemented--
they're not worth much.
And at that time, the
physical resource makers
had veto power, so
they said "No, It's
going to cost too much.
We can't do that."
But as these companies
scaled to ginormous size,
they learned the value
of internal standards
and slowly changed their mind
about external standards, too.
And part of the reason
that was possible
is because of things
like this: 1903,
the Great Baltimore Fire
wiped out Baltimore.
It was a big deal.
There were over 600 variants
of hose and size couplings,
so people showed up.
They weren't painful and rude.
They showed up, but
they couldn't help.
So things like this
made it really acutely
aware to lot of people
that we need standards,
and so they started in
the UK and then in the US
we started doing it, too.
And then, finally, I think
we're getting to the point
that I'm going to
start on here, which
is our approach to standards
has changed over time.
We've tried lots of things,
and every once in awhile we
need a little revolution
to say, "Hey, you're
not thinking about
this properly."
And it's worth learning
from what's happened before,
too, because pretty
much everything that's
been waged about standards
that we're saying now
has been waged in the past.
And here's what we know.
We know that standards are
necessary at some level.
They're really hard.
And that they're technically
better at the "last miles"
than the first ones.
They're not the greatest
source of innovation,
but they're really
the only ones that
are capable of crossing
the boundary to,
this is really a standard.
But I'm emphasizing
this: they're
trying to solve problems that
are actually fluid, right?
Environments aren't
a stasis, right?
And in the '60s, things changed.
IBM became this giant monolith
and everything was theirs.
But software changed
the game and got
us thinking about how to solve
a problem at higher levels.
Here's two things I want
to compare and contrast,
is the thing on your left is
EDI, and it was really popular.
If you wanted to do business
in the '80s you better do this.
But it's really brittle
and it's really specific,
and there's no way
that you can do cats,
It doesn't support cats.
But this thing on
the other side,
this is intellectually driven by
a small group at Cambridge IBM
and it was nurtured.
And then, when they kind
of had it figured out
and it computed a
little bit, then they
put it through standards.
And it's a really
generalized model,
and that means that
people can do new things.
Somebody came along and said,
"You know what the web needs?
Kittens."
Same thing kind of happened
with network architecture.
ISO tried to standardize
a network stack,
and they spent 10
years doing that.
But meanwhile, somewhere kind of
late through that, [INAUDIBLE]
and some guys went
to ARPA and they
focused on a smaller scale of
agreement and running code.
They got in the door, and
that's why we have the internet.
So adoption matters, again,
but there's a shift here.
Now, the makers-- they're
not pushing iron and steel,
they're pushing bits--
and bits are cheap.
So then when Tim comes
along-- Tim Burners-Lee
creates the web--
it's measurably worse
on a number of access than
a whole bunch of things
that were available at the time.
But it had a really, really
little low barrier to entry--
just view source and you're in.
And it had enough
to do useful things.
So it got started, and pretty
soon all those shortcomings
became evident and we
started to fragment
and there is this worry
that, "Oh no, now it's
just going to be chaos."
So we created the W3C.
At first there was
really great progress
because it was "last
mile" sorts of things.
There were things that already
looked kind of inevitable
and we just needed a lot of
people to finalize agreement.
But then we went down
this decade-long foray
into x-whatever or w-whatever:
XML, XSL, XPath XQuerty.
Let's just forget it.
The interesting thing
here is that developers
became the new veto-power
and important innovators.
Raise your hand if
you use XML stuff.
Not much anymore, right?
It's not what we use.
We use jQuery.
We all do use jQuery,
but we use JSON.
JSON was kind of discovered
but also kind of incubated
and happened
because we all went,
good enough, for a lot of stuff.
These high-level observations:
the technical superiority
ultimately means little.
There's all kinds of
different advantages
that it can trumpet when
we get to standard scale,
and that software is
a great equalizer.
It has the potential
to empower developers.
Standardization in the small
is easier than in the large,
and when you do it in a small
these adjacent possibles,
they become possible.
You build something and somebody
will build on top of it,
and when they build
on top of it they
won't do it in a standards body.
They'll do it out in
the open, and they
have a little bit more freedom
to make harder decisions
and get it out
there and compete.
And eventually,
when we have things
that start to look
inevitable, we
can kind of do the
archeology and find out
where the common
ground is, and then we
can send that to
a standard's body.
And if you look at
this from a distance,
it looks a lot more like a
living system than a machine.
It looks like
something evolved, not
something that's
highly, highly designed.
So here's my point, anyway.
We have changed
standards in the past,
and for good reasons when the
little revolution happened,
and I think it's time
we changed them again.
So step one is, can
we get everybody
to agree to some fundamental
principles about what we mean?
Step one is the
extensible web manifesto,
where we kind of
articulated, "This
is what we're talking about.
Can we get there?"
If you're not familiar
with it, there's
just a couple points in it that
I think are really important.
If we focus on new ideas
and standards bodies,
we should start with primitives.
Don't start with these very,
very high declarative things.
Let's start low
and let's build up
and see what happens
in getting data
and let's focus on excavating
the things that are high-level
so we can explain the magic
that's in the platform
so that we can tweak it
slightly and innovate outside.
Tighten the feedback loop.
We need to find a way
to include developers,
and traditional means,
they're not going to work.
We can't have 200,000 developers
on a mailing list every day
throwing things back and forth.
And when we do have a
spec that is laid out,
let's probably fill it.
Let's have an elementation
that's not by the browsers,
if possible.
So there are good
examples of this,
and I think we've seen some
interesting things with people
who are traditionally
spec authors doing this.
Web MIDI stuff Chris
did as a [INAUDIBLE].
Rock.
We have guys who are
authors of the HTML spec.
Some people will debate that.
Instead of just sitting
there arguing about things,
they create a tag with
Polymer and they say,
"This is what I'm
thinking, guys.
What do you think?"
And, really, a
lot of them so far
have been like, "Yeah,
we don't think so."
But that's useful
because it's turns into,
"But here's what we
can all agree on."
That's it.
How did I do for time?
You did pretty good.
[APPLAUSE]
LYZA GARDNER: So thanks,
Brian for that introduction.
"View source and you're in"
is a pretty inclusive promise.
It's part of how
we look at the web.
So now we're going to
start a little bit blunt
with some questions, but before
I do that I should mention who
the people are
sitting next to me.
Alex Russell, on the end
here, works at Google.
He works on Chrome.
He works on web workers.
He works on service workers.
Let's see.
Oh, gosh, he works
on web components.
Kind of all of the things.
And Divya Mannian,
sitting next to me here,
has her name attached to
all sorts of great things
out in the community.
A lot around HTML5.
HTML5 Please HTML5 boilerplate,
and also Move the Web Forward.
She's with Adobe.
Over here we have
Adrian Bateman.
He's with Microsoft.
He's fighting the good fight
while leading the program
manager of the developers
on Internet Explorer.
He mentioned to me that he also
wants IE8 to die in a fire,
so I thought I would
mention it on his behalf.
[APPLAUSE]
I didn't want him to have
to necessarily say that,
but he allowed me to.
So Kenneth here on
the end works at Intel
and is quite involved in
exposing device APIs on the web
where possible, including
the crosswalk run time
and also working on
Chromium within Intel.
So like I said, I'm going
to start a bit blunt here
by stating what I
guess is an opinion,
but perhaps accepted or
agreed upon by you guys.
And that is that, really,
Flexbox took forever.
There was a lot of time.
And in that respect-- looking at
it from the standards process--
where are we wasting our
time, whether on Flexbox
or other similar standards.
Where do you guys think
we're wasting our time?
And I'll let Divya
take the chair,
because she's
definitely ready for it.
DIVYA MANIAN: I
am ready for this,
I spent-- well, how
much, four years-- trying
work on the standards body.
I joined Adobe to
represent reps platform
at Adobe in the standards
bodies, and I quit in a year
and I moved to some other stuff.
And one of the reason's
is this-- wasting time,
because there's a
lot of waste of time
that happens with
standards bodies.
And Adobe, we pursue
a lot of features.
We pursue blend modes, and
blend modes are really awesome,
cool things that's
going to happen.
It's going to happen soon, guys.
It's happening.
And then there is this
[INAUDIBLE] shapes.
We worked on regions.
We spent at least
three years on regions,
which Google said, "Well,
screw your three years of work.
Too bad."
And then we did all
of our other stuff,
so there's a lot
of waste of time.
And I think this is very
important discussion to have.
And a lot of waste of time
happens in the mailing list
and in the weekly meetings.
And a lot of time it
happens because there's
somebody who has a lot of
time that you don't, and they
would be saying
something like, "I
don't agree with this
particular syntax.
It should have a bubble
or another digit,"
or something like that.
You don't have time to waste
to apply to such nonsense
but you have to, because
otherwise your proposal will
not get accepted.
So do you waste
time there or do you
do things that are interesting?
You have to decide.
And that's where most
of the time gets wasted.
LYZA GARDNER: What
you think, Alex?
I can sort of see you
squirming a touch.
ALEX RUSSELL: Well, I'm
squirming in agreement.
For background, my
most recent experience
with the pain of
Divya's is expressing
came with the promises
spec in [INAUDIBLE].
So we, in 2013 in
probably February,
had a thing that hung
together, and we sort of
had agreement on it.
The March meeting of 2013
we thought we had general
agreement about sort of a
cut-down version of an overall
promises thing that was A+
compatible that we'd spent
a bunch of time working with
stakeholders to get done.
Anyway, I'm going to fast
forward to early 2014.
Early this year we had yet
another series of flareups
after wasting something like
another six or eight months
on inconsequential debate to
try to get something done,
and largely-- heroically--
brought over the line
by Dominic.
He sort of picked
up the ball after I
rage-quit on the process.
This speaks to, on the one
hand, the exact dynamics
you're talking about,
about requiring
the notion of consensus
without getting something
valuable in people's hands.
Promises should have
been a slam dunk.
Promises should have been the
easiest thing in the world,
because every Javascript
library on the planet
has something that
looks like Promises.
And in fact, when we started
this design exercise--
Jake and [INAUDIBLE] and
I, with Dominic's help
and [? Mark Millan's ?]
help-- we
sort of went through
all of the catalogue
of the popular Promises
libraries and all
the antecedents and of the
cross-language comparisons
and tried to come up with
something that looked good
and extract the common
core out of this.
And yet, everyone
has an opinion.
It's not clear that
those standards processes
that require consensus
are necessarily
the way to make progress.
It would be better if we can
make progress through science.
We can go and we can
look at the world
and figure out who's
doing the most of what
and see what deserves to be
written down in the dictionary.
I sort of think of it
like slang in dictionary.
We grow slang, just
the way we pick up
a word then toss it out.
But if it's really
popular it gets
written into the dictionary.
LYZA GARDNER: Am I hearing that
there's too much consensus,
or is it that the questions--
ADRIAN BATEMAN:
Too much consensus?
LYZA GARDNER: Or, too much
reliance on consensus.
Or is it that the discussion
points are too broad?
ADRIAN BATEMAN: No, I think
the problem is who decides.
LYZA GARDNER: Who
should be consulted?
ADRIAN BATEMAN: Who should
be in charge of this?
Consensus means that everybody
gets to say something.
And as Alex said,
everybody has an opinion.
The reason these
things take forever
is because everybody
wants their say.
Everybody wants to put their
little stamp on the speck.
In the absence of that, if
we want to do something else,
then how do we decide who's
going to be in charge?
LYZA GARDNER: How do
we short circuit that?
What's an alternative?
ADRIAN BATEMAN: Do we
just go into a closed room
and say, you to
pay to get in here,
or you have to pass some
test to get in here,
or you have to solve some
riddle to get in here.
How do you do that?
ALEX RUSSELL: Let
me just suggest
that I think of the worst
things that we've ever
done as a series
of communities--
because it's not just one
place-- we don't talk very
much, and that's another
topic for debate here,
despite talking too
much on mailing lists.
Mailing lists are the worst
form of human communication
yet invented.
I submit this for challenge.
LYZA GARDNER: How do you
think would be a better
alternative for people to
communicate about these things?
ALEX RUSSELL: I think that
when these processes go well,
we do it by creating small
communities of people
who are both informed and
invested in the topics,
because the larger
community is going
to be able to take signals
about whether or not
something is healthy
from experts.
Not everybody is an
expert, and maybe everybody
does have an opinion, but
getting those opinions
from an opinion to
an informed opinion
generally requires that
people read up on things.
To do that, you often want to
build from a small set of tests
about an idea, and hopefully
there's competition.
But once that first primordial
set of evolutions happens,
you can start to grow
the group of people
who are invested and involved,
if the platform supports it.
We have this
challenge in a bunch
of places where
Promises are easy.
And I kept saying that
the only goal for Promises
is that there was a spec,
because the version that we
have now isn't good.
Flat-out has tons
of missing features.
It's not great,
and its large value
is that it is the one thing
that you can call Promises.
That is the place where
standards provide value,
is that we then can all
agree that it's the thing.
So you sort of have to thread
the needle to get there,
but getting that early evolution
going without requiring that
you boil an entire 2,000-person
mailing list of ideas before
anyone will start any debate
on anything is really a recipe
for failure.
We've been
experimenting with using
Git Hub to build new things.
That's only one attempt.
DIVYA MANIAN: The one
thing that I want to say
is I feel like most of the
browser windows lack trust.
They don't trust anybody else.
They think Google
engineers are the best
at doing what is to be done.
Microsoft engineers
will think the same way.
[INAUDIBLE] would think
the same way, too.
So that lack of
trust-- that means
that outside players like Adobe
and Intel-- when they come in,
they basically don't
have any leg to stand on
and they will have to depend
on somebody else to verify
[INAUDIBLE].
And then politics
enters into the play,
and then it becomes
like, "Well, is
your feature important
to our vested interests?"
And then--
ALEX RUSSELL: I want to submit
the experience of service
workers as a key--
LYZA GARDNER: Alex,
we're going to be
able to talk about
service workers
specifically in
the next question,
so I want to make
sure that we get it.
I am neglecting our
audience members,
because they're behind me and
I wasn't paying attention.
But we've got a number
of people queued up who
would like to ask or
make comments about this.
AUDIENCE: So
actually my response
IS from something probably
five or six minutes ago,
because I was queued
up that long ago,
but I just wanted to say,
in the terms of consensus,
no successful software project
works by multi-vendor consensus
in building the project.
We have the project lead.
So I just think that's
an interesting thing
to keep in mind when you say,
"How can we be successful?"
And the web has a
lot more constraints
because we are shipping
literally multiple pieces
of software, multiple
browsers, that
need to implement these things.
But that's partially, probably,
why we're in such a situation.
LYZA GARDNER: And I want to make
sure we got Jonas ready to go.
Brian, yep?
BRIAN KARDELL: I'd just like to
offer as something to consider
is that the best
thing is actually
the best thing you
can actually get.
So what we see in history
throughout all these things,
and what Alex was just saying
here, there are problems.
It's not the best Promises,
but it's standard Promises,
and that's pretty awesome.
LYZA GARDNER: Shipping
is a good feature.
BRIAN KARDELL: What
we need is a way
to shortcut a lot
of these things
and figure out how to grow
them in the community.
One of things I'm
working on is how
we can set up meetups
that engage developers
and have them review specs and
work on prollyfills and things,
and feed that without all of the
noise back into the groups so
that we can avoid-- you guys
were talking about regions.
How long was that, four years?
OK, there are features
in CSS that are 15 years.
I have envy of your delays.
LYZA GARDNER: Jonas, I'd like
you to get a chance here.
AUDIENCE: One of the
comments that Alex
made was that having a
small group of people that
are actually informed is
extremely important to find
a right-size group with
the right set of people.
We have two extremes,
for example.
[INAUDIBLE] who does
the [INAUDIBLE] version
of HTML, who many times
sort of goes alone.
At least, this is the
impression that I have.
I guess I should just
speak for myself.
Basically the working mode
there is generally the editor
decides.
He tries to collect
as much information
to make a scientifically
correct decision.
And then on the other side, we
have actually, funnily enough,
the same specification in
the W3C space, where there's
a mailing list of hundreds
of people and everyone
opines about every single
thing, and every opinion
is expressed with
extremely little data:
"This is my experience having
written this one website,
and I want a feature that
implements my whole website
in a single tag."
That also results,
basically, in disaster.
And so Dave [? Herman ?] who
I'll speak for a little bit
here, tends to talk about
the layers of an onion
where you start with a
small group of people
and then slowly grow
that and take input.
But instead of shooting off
your proposal to a mailing list,
actually seek out
people you think
could have valuable
information, and then
adjust the proposal as the
group of experts grows.
LYZA GARDNER: I want to get
[? Yulav's ?] feedback on this,
and then I want to move
on the next question.
AUDIENCE: Regarding what
Divya said regarding
browser vendors and trust--
that, for example, Chrome
doesn't trust people outside
Google-- my personal experience
was that this is
really not the case.
And the Opera folks, also,
they have all the trust
in the world when it comes
to doing [INAUDIBLE] work.
I don't think that's
true as a general rule.
And regarding
everything Alex said,
I just want to support it.
Again, the RICG's
experience is that we
have to form small groups of
developers and various browser
vendors and work in a focused
way on a single problem,
get it solved, move on.
Otherwise, it drags forever.
LYZA GARDNER: Thanks.
KENNETH CHRISTIANSEN: think
we've seen a lot of success
in that lately with
people doing smaller specs
and trying to have more focus.
One of the working
groups we did.
The opposite was the
sysapps working group,
where we tried to solve all
the problems of the world
and we produced
absolutely nothing
until people said, "Why?
Can't we do simple things
like the [INAUDIBLE] spec?"
One function, very simple.
You can standardize it.
Then you can go
and ask developers.
You can get feedback.
The developers
actually understand
what they're looking
at, because if you
have this huge that
no one will read it.
The developers, they don't
get all these small details.
The wording is
slightly different.
And then you don't
get the feedback,
and then, first, at the last
mile, where this is almost
becoming a standard,
then everyone drops in
and they give all their
different opinions.
And everything goes,
"Oh my, I thought
we were on the same page.
What's happening now?"
That's probably what you saw
with Promises, as well, right?
LYZA GARDNER: I'm
hearing a few things
here before we move
on to the next topic.
I'm hearing a lot of
notion that there's
a lot of noise in the
process and that we're
working on things that are
a little bit monolithic,
and if we break
those down into tasks
that are more manageable
by smaller teams, that
can help us move faster.
So I'm going to move on
to another discussion
about something that
a number of people
view as something that
didn't go quite right.
I guess the way
that I worded it is
that AppCache was
kind of a train wreck.
In light of how the
standards process is evolving
or changing, maybe a
little bit for the better,
are there changes that
have been happening
that can help Service Worker be
more successful than AppCache
was?
ALEX RUSSELL: Well, I want
to start by giving credit
to Andrew Betts
and Jake Archibald
for getting the process
started that has ended up
at a place where
Service Worker's getting
implemented quite broadly.
Obviously it's my
feature, so I'm
going to say it looks great.
But the process
was fundamentally
different to the way that
AppCache was designed.
The history here is that
there was a project called
Google Gears, which
attempted to flesh out
some of these ideas in
a hostile environment.
It had to be a plug-in for
IE, because IE was dead.
It had to be a
plug-in for Safari
because there wasn't really much
to be done, and for Firefox.
And so it was difficult.
It had to be implemented
multiple times.
But it came up
with one solution,
and then it was clear that
Gears was going to die,
and so one when Chrome
came about it was like,
"Well, let's get
everything into HTML."
So there was a
deliberative process
of writing down what Gears did.
And AppCache, to
[INAUDIBLE] credit,
is a coherent way of thinking
about exactly what Gears
did inside of HTML, without
reexamining whether or not
it was a good idea
or a bad idea.
It had the fundamental flaw of
being a very high-level feature
without any
extensibility whatsoever,
so that when something
goes wrong with AppCache --
and much the way when
something goes wrong with CSS,
it's effectively a closed box.
You're completely
screwed because you
have none of the
latent power of any
of the intermediate
systems in there.
Think about how an
image is requested.
An image starts with
an image element,
and then it goes to the network.
It fetches some stuff.
It gets some bytes back.
It picks an image decoder.
It decodes it and
it paints them.
These are all steps
that we can enumerate,
things that there should be
APIs for, and in some cases,
there are in the platform.
But you can plug it
in just a bit of image
when you want to override,
say, an image format.
That panel made me nuts.
We're sitting here thinking
about how Mozilla may or may
not approach a particular
image format in the future,
without any data and no
ability whatsoever for us
as a community to go plug
in our own image decoders,
despite the fact that
every browser represented
here has invested
very heavily in ASMJS
and has workers
with transferables.
We could be doing image
decoding on our own,
off-thread, if there was a way
to plumb in our own image data
the images and just be part of
that image request life cycle.
It is crazy pants that we
can't be part of that today,
that we're sitting here
having a debate about what
browser vendors with a lot of
power are going to do tomorrow.
That is the goal of the
extensible web manifesto,
is to get us to a place
where things are layered
and explained in
such a way where
and plug-in when you
want some of the power
or you want to play
inside the framework
but don't want to have to
reinvent the whole thing.
LYZA GARDNER: So inaccessibility
is definitely an issue here.
I want to make sure the
audience on the floor
gets at the chance to ask--
does Mark already have a-- yup.
AUDIENCE: I was on the
queue for the last one.
LYZA GARDNER: Oh,
I'm sorry about that.
Is anyone ready to speak
to this current discussion
or should I stick with
the panel for the moment?
Jonas, again.
I think it's David.
David Barron back there.
ADRIAN BATEMAN: While
we're waiting for them,
I think App Cache
is a great example
of all kinds of train wreck.
It's not just one problem.
This is the perfect case study
in how not to build a feature.
LYZA GARDNER: Like?
ADRIAN BATEMAN: It was
in the spec in 2008
and it was there for years,
littered in tiny pieces
throughout this huge
monolithic spec that
was very difficult for anybody
to evaluate because there
were 70 tiny pieces of it.
We've heard, in several
of the sessions today,
this desire to focus
on small problems.
To work on one
problem at a time,
to define this in a way
which is comprehensible
and not just by
standard [INAUDIBLE]
but by web developers as well.
I think that's one of
the problems, as well,
with AppCache was it was
really hard to review and see
how it was going to work
and how it interacted
with other parts of the system.
ALEX RUSSELL: But
it also was an API,
so it wasn't possible to just
sort of sit down and write down
some code, and Jake comes
back to this concept a lot
of, sit down and
write down some code
and say, "How would my thing
interact with this if I was
just even reasoning
about the control flow?"
Because there's no control flow.
It's only high level.
And so the appeal
that we've come
to-- first with Web Components
and now with Service Worker--
is to say, "Look, we don't
necessarily know the answer
and we're not going
to pretend like we're
going to figure this
out on a mailing list.
It is the worst
possible environment
for detecting software fitness."
LYZA GARDNER: So no
mailing list, that's what--
ALEX RUSSELL: No, a mailing
list might be fine or something.
I haven't identified
what it is yet,
but it might be
fine for something.
But it's also terrible at
defining software fitness.
LYZA GARDNER:
[INTERPOSING VOICES] decision
by list.
So David out in the
audience, would you
like to have your say?
Are we short a microphone again?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
No, I have a microphone.
Two things.
It rubbed me wrong
way a little bit when
Alex said it's crazy pants that
we don't have this API already.
You have to recognize
that the web has
evolved to the state it's in.
It's evolved from
something really simple.
And sure, we should have
add a lot of these things,
but the reason it
got to where it was
is because we started
with something simple
and now you're back-killing
it with these primitives.
I think the other
important point
about adding more primitives
to is that sometimes when
you talk about adding
primitives you're
exposing primitives
that already exist.
And sometimes there aren't
really clear primitives
that already exist and you
have to make new primitives
and then rebuild
what you already
have on top of those things.
And the second thing is a
lot more work than the first.
I agree that in some cases
we do want to do that work,
but you have to recognize that
it is a lot more work for.
ALEX RUSSELL: For context
here-- Chris Wilson
is going to hate me
bringing this up--
but I continue to bring up
the notion that the Web Audio
specification should have
some sort of relationship
to how audio is played
through the audio tag,
or through the video tag.
That seems like a
pretty clear bit
of layering that you should
have in the platform,
and we don't have it.
And it is a lot of work
and I'm willing to be
patient about these things, but
I do think that, as a group,
we should be impatient
about making progress
in this direction.
We should not accept
the idea that this
is the endpoint
that we would like,
or that because it happened
to have evolved to this place
that the next quantum of time
should look like this one.
Progress means doing
something differently.
LYZA GARDNER: So Brian,
it looks like you
might have a thought on this.
BRIAN KARDELL: I do.
LYZA GARDNER: I want to get
Ilya and Natasha queued up
to have their say, as well.
BRIAN KARDELL: So this is just
kind of a common thing that
comes up where we have a
big, deep system like CSS
and Layout and
everything, and there
are bits of that that are
not even actually speced.
They just exist.
So there's this box tree that
isn't really accurately defined
anywhere, and so everybody
kind of implemented something
different.
I think, actually, one
browser-- who I won't name--
doesn't even actually have
a box tree, technically.
It's just something that you can
observe, like its spooky action
from a distance.
You know it's there.
It's kind of described.
Everybody talks about it, but
it it's not really specced out.
And it's not the first
time we've had this.
So yes, it means we
might have to invent
some things to describe
those spooky sorts of things,
but that's good.
And even if it's imperfect,
it's still the best we can get.
LYZA GARDNER: It's a thing.
It's a something.
BRIAN KARDELL: Right.
LYZA GARDNER: Did we lose Ilya?
AUDIENCE: Nope.
LYZA GARDNER: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I want to come back
to something that, Alex, you
said earlier, which is
we want to do science,
or we want to have some data
and metrics and all the rest.
And I'm hearing a lot
of good discussion
in terms of how do we improve
the process for generating
the spec and getting good
feedback and all the rest.
But even if-- let's assume I'm
successful at that-- I then
take that proposal to
the vendors and they say,
oh but now you need
commitment from everybody.
Who else is shipping this thing,
because I'm not shipping it
unless you're shipping it, and
we can't ship it because if I
ship it and then we can unship
it, and then we're stuck.
LYZA GARDNER: So you go first.
AUDIENCE: How do
we do science if we
can't ship things
that may go wrong?
ALEX RUSSELL: It's
a great point.
I'm hopeful about the work
we did in Web Components
to sort of open up the
HTML parser to everybody,
because what it's
going to allow us to do
is to use parses and
metrics that we grabbed
from telemetry to understand
which things are really
common in the world so
that we can actually make
a data-driven case
about who's using what,
and figure out whether
or not it's important.
This is the same
sort of data that we
use these days to
evaluate whether or not
a feature is allowed to die.
One of the sort of electrified
fences of the web platform
is the idea of ever taken
anything back and breaking
some portion of
the web's content.
And it's only been
recently that we've
started to use histogram
data in Chrome telemetry
to start informing
this question,
and we can start to do
quite a bit more of that.
And so I'm hopeful that, as we
open up these new primitives,
we can start to see, on one
hand, the popular libraries.
We've got central
repositories impact managers.
Thank god.
I remember trying to build
big JavaScript without them.
So, good on ya, and we'll be
able to get some information
from them.
We'll start to be able to see
and instrument what's important
in the run times
at the API level,
and we'll start to be able to
instrument things from crawls
to sort of understand what sorts
of patterns people are using
and how they're composing them.
And I'm hopeful that these
will provide a basic form.
There's a lot more
than we can do.
There's lots more
instrumentation that we
can come up with, and
I'm hopeful that we'll
start to prioritize and
use a confidence interval
the same sort of how much data,
how good is it, how fresh is it
sorts of things that we use to
make decisions about removing
[INAUDIBLE] today.
ADRIAN BATEMAN: I just want to
give a note of caution, though.
I'm certainly in
favor of us exploring
having different
primitives available.
The thing which I
really worry about
is, as we start to look at
things like the box model
or various other parts of
the internals of browsers--
which, as a browser vendor,
we spend a huge amount of time
researching, innovating,
trying to improve performance
for-- that every time we expose
a primitive that describes some
of that implementation we risk
pinning that implementation
and removing the opportunity
to innovate that black box.
And so I don't think
that it's always the case
that a black box is a bad thing.
I think sometimes
LYZA GARDNER: It's a
place for abstraction.
ADRIAN BATEMAN: Yeah.
It allows us to innovate
in ways which we might not
be able to do if we
expose everything.
ALEX RUSSELL: I'll
see your caution
and raise you the recent
history of the [INAUDIBLE].
LYZA GARDNER: I want to
give Natasha a chance
to ask her question,
because she has
been waiting an
awfully long time.
NATASHA: That's OK.
I'll try and be quick.
Just going back to
the small teams thing,
one of the issues
with small teams--
although I think it's the
right way to go forward--
is that when you take the
spec to a larger audience,
then everybody wants to
go through the issues
of how did you come
to those decisions,
and how did you
get to that point?
And it's one of my
jobs as a technologist
I have to go through these
decisions very often.
I'm getting some
feedback here, so I'm
going to take a step this way.
Going back to the stuff happened
that with Service Worker, one
of the things I really liked
was the explainer document.
It wasn't a spec.
It was just an
explainer document.
And I know you guys
were the people that
were involved in
writing that, but that
made my job so much easier.
I didn't have to
ask you about why
you came to those solutions
or the reasoning behind it.
It was all included that.
LYZA GARDNER: You're getting
ahead, in that sense.
Getting ahead of the
questions that you kind of
are inevitable
about legitimizing.
NATASHA: Exactly.
You have planned for them,
and they're saying, "Here.
We had this issue and we
came up with a situation."
and so people have problems,
they go, "Go hang out.
Go have a look at the
explainer document."
That could be something to
take forward to other specs.
LYZA GARDNER: Great.
I've got to move us forward.
We're running a little
bit behind here,
so I want to pull us
forward and actually
talk a little bit about the
manifesto we've been skirting
around just a bit, in terms of
how it would advise if it were
followed, the extensible
web manifesto,
us to be thinking
about standards
as we're moving forward.
Specifically, I
thought we could talk
about-- this is a question
inspired by one submitted
by Sam [? Giles. ?] The
manifesto encourages
the exposure of low
level standards,
or granularity on a low level.
But APIs like Beacon kind
of fly in the face of that.
They're higher level.
Looking at that
API in particular,
as it's moving forward here,
how would we reconcile that gap?
What things is it
doing that are in line
with the tenets
of the manifesto,
and what things
really differ from it?
ADRIAN BATEMAN: So
I think the problem
with taking Beacon and
doing that-- using some
of these lower
level primitives--
ultimately comes
down to performance.
And this is another area that
I worry about with the approach
of making everything low level.
So it's true that we could
build the Beacon API, which
is a way of having a page
send some data to a server,
even if it's during unload so
you don't have to wait around
for the response to that.
It's true that you could build
that using a Service Worker.
But we have lots of
concerns around the impact
that Service Worker might have
on the performance of page
loading.
We spend a lot of time on
getting pages time to glass
and the focus on that, and
the counterargument to that
has always been, "Well,
ServiceWorker is a pay for play
thing.
If you want to use ServiceWorker
then when you accept that
that might have some impact."
Which is fine except this is
for analytics, Which is probably
going to be on every page, and
now suddenly have a Service
Worker on every page
and now every page
is paying this penalty.
And I'm not sure that's
the right way to go always,
and so maybe there's a
place for a simple API.
This is pretty short
spec that just says,
"Here's a way of sending--
LYZA GARDNER: So is this
an example of a spec,
an API that's concise
enough that it's
easy to just knock
out and get done?
Or does it have
conflicts, do you think?
Brian, do you have
a [INAUDIBLE]?
BRIAN KARDELL: I
think that we have
to evaluate these things
on a case by case basis,
and not everything can be
exposed at the lowest level
possible.
And I think that where we
choose to do that is debatable.
At one point there
was discussion
about whether we should
have block storage.
That's really low level and like
nobody writes block storage.
And some other people said,
"OK, that's kind of crazy.
But maybe up a level,
that make sense."
I don't know that there's
always a one-size-fits-all,
go-to answer.
There might be some
things we can't get down.
But we should think about it.
Sensor's is a really good one.
Sensor's pretty low level.
It's, I think, a hardware.
But there are people
working on a standard, hey,
there's how you do
sensors-- all of them.
And it's actually pretty great.
LYZA GARDNER: Divya's
shaking her head a bit.
DIVYA MANNIAN:
First of all, I feel
like me missing the point
of browsers live forever.
That's a thing that happens.
Browsers live forever.
People are still using a lot
of old antiquated browsers.
It doesn't even have
to be antiquated.
People have different
hardware systems,
and if my mom's using
an old version of Mac,
then she can't use
the newest Chrome.
She can't use the
newest Firefox.
She's stuck with Firefox
3.4, or something like that,
and then she browses
the web using that.
And that means a lot of
web appears broken to her,
and she asked me why that's
the case, and I'm like,
I don't know what to say to her.
If you expose all these low
level APIs, and at some point
some people are going to be
limited by their hardware
configurations to a certain
version of the browser,
and what do you do then?
Do you forever support
this low level API?
Or are you going to just say no?
KENNETH CHRISTIANSEN: Exactly.
Hardware is really,
really difficult,
because if you take
something like a camera,
the technology
changes every year.
So if you make low
level primitives
to how a camera works
today, well, those
might not exist
two years from now
and there might be new
low level primitives.
Once in awhile you need
to look at the use-case.
Maybe it's fine when we have
something higher level API,
like we did with the
presentation API.
It's higher level and
it solved a use case.
LYZA GARDNER: Jake, did
we leave you behind?
JAKE: No, not quite.
I was just wanting to
agree with Adrian, really.
I feel that sometimes by some
the extensible web manifesto
is interpreted as, "We must only
add things to the platform that
are the lowest
level that we can."
I think we don't
want to do that.
I want async local storage.
I don't want to be told, "No,
you must use index db for that.
I want to be able to use
event target on my objects
rather than include
the library for it.
Query selects a role
was a good idea.
We should do that more.
ALEX RUSSELL: By
the way, I supported
implementing Beacon
in Chrome, because I
would prefer that we make
progress and figure out
how to clean it up.
I would prefer that we have
a principled way for thinking
about how to make the
connections between the things
in the platform over time.
I don't want this idea to get
in the way of giving developers
more power, specifically if
there are new areas where
there's a thing you can't do.
Well, I think the job
one is to give developers
away to freaking do
it, and then job two
is to figure out how that works.
And so job isn't done if
you only do the first part,
and we've for a very long
time settled on the notion
that we might be
binding ourselves
into some sort of
particular architecture
if we expose it as a way
of not doing job two.
And I wanted to push back on
that a little bit on that,
because I think the recent
history of JavaScript VMs
shows pretty dramatically that
you can still make forward
progress, even when the
water in front of you
looks treacherous
and full of sharks.
As long as you can figure out
ways to go fast when you're not
being asked to do a very
specific thing, then
in the general case you can
still accelerate things.
LYZA GARDNER: All right.
I want to hear from Chris
out in the audience.
CHRIS: Alex mentioned
earlier the audio element,
and him hassling
me about how you
build the audio
element as a primitive.
And what we're
doing in Web Audio
is actually totally
relevant to this question,
because we've gone and
built this Web Audio
API that's actually
pretty high level.
On purpose it was high
level, but then we
didn't expose all
the low level stuff.
We didn't expose the how
do you get an audio output
device where it just keeps
asking you for more bits
and you just have to keep
pumping more bits to it?
But the problem, to
my mind-- because this
was a suggestion from Robert
O'Callahan from Mozilla early
on-- the problem
is if you only do
that, you're going to
miss a lot of developers.
Like me, for example.
I never would have
started getting
into audio
programming on the web
if I didn't have an
API that I could have
built this stuff
on top of easily.
I think this calls out
you have to do both.
So now I'm going back
through the audio API
and recasting it as
this layered API where
you could think of it in
these very primitive terms,
particularly because that also
lets us innovate in the future.
It also lets us decide, "Hey,
we need a new type of element
in Web Audio that
isn't there today,
and we want to try it
out in JavaScript."
We want to basically polyfill
it without having to go
and hand code it into Chrome
and into webkit and everything
else.
So this idea of, there
are multiple levels
that may be really
interesting to developer
for is a really critical
one to understand.
LYZA GARDNER: So it doesn't
sound like it's necessarily
at odds with the manifesto.
CHRIS: Not at all.
LYZA GARDNER: It's
just different ways
of interpretation, and general
ideas that avoiding orthodoxy
and being particularly
fundamental about it, maybe.
ALEX RUSSELL: The manifesto
begs follow-on questions,
and I think those questions
need to be answered.
LYZA GARDNER: Interpretation.
BRIAN KARDELL: So low is
a relative term, right?
I mean open for interpretation.
LYZA GARDNER: And devil's
advocate here-- would it
help to revisit sort of the
initial text that screams out
from the manifesto
to sort of explain
what it means by low level.
Is that something that can be
perhaps a little bit difficult
to--
ALEX RUSSELL: People
can just email us.
BRIAN KARDELL: Yeah.
ALEX RUSSELL: We're not dead.
BRIAN KARDELL: Send it to the
mailing list is a good idea.
LYZA GARDNER: Oh,
the mailing list.
Oh, all right.
[LAUGHTER] I'll do that.
BRIAN KARDELL: Send
it to [INAUDIBLE].
LYZA GARDNER: Yeah.
DIVYA MANNIAN: I'll
troll everybody.
LYZA GARDNER: Mark,
got a comment?
MARK: Yeah.
I've historically been
a little skeptical
about the extensible
web manifesto-- hopeful,
but skeptical-- and
this conversation's
making me feel a bit
better about it, I guess,
in that I'm hearing a focus
on the low and the high level.
And I think about
this in terms of where
I'm a little more
comfortable, maybe the ITF,
where we didn't just
come up with HTTP.
We also did TCP/IP.
We did the low
level capabilities,
and then allowed people
to build on top of that.
So that makes me
feel better, I guess.
There was that blog
entry that somebody
did-- what, about two
weeks ago-- that Alex,
you responded to.
And I had some
sympathy with that,
because one of the
scenarios we have here is we
have these low
level capabilities.
You look at NPM
and the mess that
is the NPM package
system, because there's
a lot of low level libraries
and people building
and you get this kind of
chaos. [INAUDIBLE] that
have blogged really effectively
about that a while back.
BRIAN KARDELL: You mean by
messy you mean beautiful chaos?
MARK: Thousands of
flowers blooming,
including some
poisonous flowers, yes.
And I liked your
response to that.
I think it is beautiful chaos.
I think that's OK,
but it is something
that has to be managed
over the lifetime of what
we're doing, too.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, and I think
that is the legitimate rule
for standards, by the way.
MARK: Yeah.
ALEX RUSSELL: Once things
become clearly standard,
it is worth taking a
look and GC'ing, right?
Get the junk out and
go write that stuff
in that has survived
this evolutionary cycle
into the dictionary.
That is the goal of evolution,
is not for all organisms
to continue to live.
t is for the organisms
that are fit to survive
to the next generation.
MARK: And that was my comment
the first time around,
which was so many people
come to standards work
with stars in their eyes
and say, "Well, I just
have to get it in the
standard and it'll be real,
and we're doing R&D
here," and I just
want to find ways to
kill those people.
LYZA GARDNER: All right.
MARK: This is about
consolidation.
It's about building a platform
that we can agree upon,
and then building
value on top of that.
ALEX RUSSELL: And
my strategy here
is to build markets in
which they can fail.
MARK: Exactly.
LYZA GARDNER: All right.
So I want to keep us
moving a little bit.
Let's shift directions just a
bit right now, in terms of I
want to talk a little
bit about the gap that
exists between APIs--
especially device APIs-- exposed
for Web in browsers versus
that which you have access
to natively.
Are there tactics that we can
use-- and some of the stuff
we haven't talked about--
to move things faster
to close that gap
a bit, or is always
going to be a game of catch up?
And what can we do
about it, if anything?
KENNETH CHRISTIANSEN:
Well, I think
we have seen a lot of
progress since we tried
to make like smaller specs and
solve small use cases instead
of trying to solve
really big use cases,
like, "Oh, we're going to
make a Bluetooth API so let's
solve everything you
could do with Bluetooth."
No, let's try to solve those
things that people need
or they really
want here and now.
Something like the
device orientation lock.
People want to be able
to lock their screen.
So it's a very small spec.
The problem is, I think, the
biggest gap is time to market.
We need to be quick at
shipping these new things.
LYZA GARDNER: So
how do we do that?
Are we still talk
about the same things
we've been talking
about, like less
of a net thrown around
huge consensus building.
Less infighting.
Fewer people working.
Are those the kinds of things?
ALEX RUSSELL: I have a heretical
suggestion, if that's OK.
LYZA GARDNER: Heretical,
here it comes.
ALEX RUSSELL: My colleague
Jeff [INAUDIBLE] is at the back
and he's working on
a Bluetooth spec,
and Bluetooth is a particularly
terrible and terrifying aspect
of all of this because it is
very much a hardware spec,
and you can get things wrong
and you can break devices.
If you talk at the wrong level,
as Jeff has given me a tour of,
you can totally brick
devices that you carry around
in your pocket with
you, and that's bad.
And exposing that to the
web is clearly dangerous.
At the same time, we
have a security model.
It's called the
Origin model, and we
have a lot of capabilities
that we don't have a way
to expose today, and the way
we start getting capabilities
into the web is by
getting everyone in a room
and going, "Guys,
guys, what's the API?"
Which has a bunch of
implicit questions about it.
And that idea of sorting out
the API before you provide
the capability at some very
low level is quite difficult,
and so we don't have any
really narrow channels--
common channels--
to map capabilities
onto URLs for things which we
don't have a standard for yet.
And Dmitiri Glaskov who helped
write the original explainer
document for Web
Components-- which we just
copied for the Service
Worker, basically--
he has this idea called
navigator dot connect, which
is just sort of way of
thinking about mapping
a bunch of other things into
Service Workers and Origins,
and maybe that could be
devices on your system.
Obviously it's up to the
system to mediate it,
but that's one
possible way forward
where we have a very,
very, very narrow API
and it's up to run times to
provide some sort of mapping
to those capabilities.
LYZA GARDNER: Jonas
JONAS: I actually don't think
that sort of extensible web
is going to help
with device APIs.
The main problem we have
with device APIs is security.
We just don't know how
to expose certain things
to the web, given the web's
current security model.
LYZA GARDNER: So device APIs are
sort of special in this sense?
They don't--
JONAS: Well, yes, in a sense.
There's more things
than device APIs
that are limited by
security, but that that's
a very good example.
And I actually think that device
API is a very good example
of a place where exposing
the low level primitives
isn't the right thing to do.
So we've actually had
file access on the web
for over a decade--
maybe two, even--
in the form of input
type equals file.
It's a very terrible
API but it has gotten us
through these many,
many years and it
has allowed us to
very powerful things.
We have yet to figure out
how to expose the low level
version of that, which is
raw, file level access where
a website could just
enumerate your hard drive
and find all the images
and play all your music.
That'll be super cool
once we figure it out,
but if that's was
the first thing we
went to, then we would still
not have a lot of the things
that we have to today,
like probably not YouTube.
LYZA GARDNER: So in a
sense, though, you're
kind of saying that something
low-ish level that was exposed
has actually been
extremely useful.
JONAS: It could've
been useful, but if we
had made that the only
thing we have worked on then
I think we would have failed.
And so by going to higher levels
and only doing higher level,
we were able to at least
move forward a little bit.
And I agree.
It's good when we can
do the low level thing,
but especially when
it comes to security
you can actually often
solve security problems
by going to higher level.
LYZA GARDNER: I want
to hear from Vincent
and then I want to move
on to our next question.
VINCENT: So I'll keep it short
because Jonas particularly
addressed some of the points.
I'm working on the Bluetooth
API with Jeffrey [? Askin ?]
on the Chrome team,
as well, and I
think that-- to generalize
how do we move faster
on device APIs--
it's to figure out
the generalized
problem of dealing
with the hard security
and privacy issues,
finding a template that works,
and being able to employ that
to new APIs moving forward
where we don't have
to go through the entire process
again and open up questions
from scratch.
LYZA GARDNER: I
think that's great.
Really, it seems sort of obvious
when you think about it, right?
A repeatable approach, and
it seems pretty feasible.
And I really want
us to get a chance
to talk about this next
question just a bit,
because I think it'll
give everyone a chance
to get a few things off their
chest if they so desire.
I was wondering if some you
might have opinions or be
able to identify what specific
newer evolving APIs seem
to be suffering the most from
flaws in the process right now.
Are there pet
things that you have
in mind that you think really
could benefit from improvements
to the standards process?
ADRIAN BATEMAN: Yeah, every API.
Every single one.
They're all broken.
And there's a variety
of opinions in this room
and elsewhere about what a
possible fix might look like,
and there's this
continuum of we just
want it to be a living
document, this living standard,
this oxymoron of a document
that's never actually
a standard because it's
always changing versus
the opposite end of the
spectrum of standards
that are never useful because
they're always out of date.
And I think this is actually
the most important problem
that we have to solve.
If we can find a
happy medium for how
we can take in
proposals for new ideas
and not mix them up with the
things which are stabilizing,
and not mix them up
with the things that
are agreed on and shipped, then
I think all of the API design,
all of the standardization
process will get better.
I think that's
actually the biggest
problem we face right now.
LYZA GARDNER: Divya?
DIVYA MANNIAN: I
agree with Adrian,
because I feel
like there's a rush
to focus on cool new
features while not focusing
on the fundamental
structure of deciding
on the cool new
features, and that
leads to a lot of nonsense
features being on the web.
And then we are like, "Oh shit,
we should not have done that."
And then we are like,
"Oh well, it's there."
LYZA GARDNER: Give me
an example of something.
DIVYA MANNIAN: AppCache,
that we just discussed.
Why would we want to
have these things?
And I think we are
skirting the issue
of the fundamental
structural problem
by keeping talking about the
new features and new stuff.
I feel like there should
be a strong tendency
to say no new
features while fixing
underlying fundamental issues.
LYZA GARDNER: Larry,
I want to hear from--
LARRY: I have a lot to say
about the standards process,
but in particular
answer to this question
there's a lot of
the web platform
that is not being worked on
and that the standards are not
very good.
It's old stuff, and who
wants to work on old stuff?
People come to the
process thinking
that it's a place for
innovation and new ideas
when it's really for review.
LYZA GARDNER: What's
an example of something
that's languishing?
LARRY: The file URL scheme.
How do you translate
files and the file name
to a URL that works?
If I want to put a
website on a thumb drive
and carry it to
somebody else and then
open it up with file URLs,
it's completely platform
independent.
And then every operating
system does it differently.
Every implementation
is different,
and there's nobody who
particularly cares about this,
even though it seems like
an important application.
ALEX RUSSELL: I
think that's untrue.
It's just that you need to put
a web server on the thumb drive.
LARRY: Thank you.
I'll talk to Sandisk.
ADRIAN BATEMAN: But I think
this is a general problem.
This general problem
with, it's really cool.
Everybody gets
props for coming up
with new ideas and brand new
things that they want to do.
And finishing
things-- figuring out
the detail-- that's actually
the really difficult part.
And so I'd really
like it if we could
find the right model for us
to spend time figuring out
some of those
details, and we seem
to spend a huge amount of
time-- on my team-- trying
to figure out, why does this
website work in this browser
and not in this browser?
Why does this thing
not quite work?
Why does this not
quite lay out right?
And it's because the
devil's in the detail,
and trying to figure out this
detail-- doing that last mile--
is actually really difficult .
We need to find a better way
of actually figuring that out.
DIVYA MANNIAN: I want
to add one more thing.
The thing that I
want to add is if you
are suggesting cool new
features and advocating
for cool new features
like Flexbox,
make sure you provide the
debugging tools to help debug
these cool new features,
too, instead of just going
out and talking
to everybody else,
"You should use Flexbox
today because it's so cool.
Here's this cool demo."
But where is the
debugging tools for this?
You need to provide those, too.
LYZA GARDNER: So getting
all the way there, huh?
So Jake and, I
think, Mark, let's
hear what you guys have
to say really quick.
JAKE: Quick one, I think
that the APIs suffering
the most at the moment are
those that are being needlessly
forked by the W3,
because now have
two specs for the same
thing and that's pointless.
[APPLAUSE]
LYZA GARDNER: Give
me some examples.
Give me some examples?
JAKE: XMLH HTTP request.
HTML.
URL, as well.
LYZA GARDNER: Mark,
are you out there?
There you are.
MARK: Sorry if I'm beating
a dead horse from before--
LYZA GARDNER: This
is all dead horses.
MARK: I have to go back
to the low level thing.
I know we keep
coming back to that,
and that seems to be a
big point of contention.
So I personally am a big
believer in abstraction.
I agree a lot with what
Adrian was saying about missed
opportunities if you
don't provide abstraction.
I'll give you the argument
about being more nimble
and providing more low level
access, enabling developers.
Let's say you are able to
reform the standards process,
do these small focus groups,
be very task-oriented,
move things quickly.
How do you avoid missing
the boat, though,
on larger architectural arcs of
opportunities for abstraction?
LYZA GARDNER: I'm going
to give Alex a chance
to answer because he looks very
antsy, and then got to wrap.
ALEX RUSSELL: So the
answer there is, hopefully
there is a super structure in
which these efforts take place.
And so some of my fellow
reformers about this process
have recently run to the W3C
technical architecture group.
And one, I was turned
out for process reasons--
Dominic joined and so we
worked for the same company.
Anyway, long story
short, the hope
is that there is a body
that can redirect enthusiasm
for new features into
questions about how
you explain the old
things, instead.
To put pressure back on the
question of how does it work,
because it's probably
already in there.
The web is so big.
It's so freaking big.
The API surface
area is enormous,
and the implicit API
surface area is even larger
that the odds are that the
answer is probably already
in there someplace.
You just need to go dig it out.
So instead of giving me a
new CSS property, dig it out.
Give me API and come
back and talk to me.
LYZA GARDNER: All right.
So, panelists,
thank you so much.
There's a lot of stuff going on.
I think there's a lot of
the questions people still
want to talk about, but I think
we ran the gamut fairly well.
We talked about how the amount
of noise in the standards
processes is hampering
it to some extent.
The scope of some
of the projects
may be too large
to be efficient,
and that there's some
languishing, less-sexy APIs
out there that could use love
just as much as anything else.
So I thank you guys quite a lot.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW BETTS: Thanks, guys.
So that is it, but
don't go anywhere,
because I have a few
wrap-up things to say,
and then we have the
party to go to Akamai.
So just give us a second.
We have a few technical
issues with the final slides.
One of the things
we'll be doing now
is giving out some
of the prizes.
You have to be in the
room to win a prize,
so if you're on this list
and you're not in the room
then we will just roll
the dice and give it
to anyone randomly
who is in the room.
So if you feel eligible to
win a prize this evening
then you need to get
your phone out and go
to an on-slide URL,
which will hopefully
be coming up on the
screen in a second.
I'm told that Google, Adobe,
and Akamai employees are exempt.
[BOOING]
So sorry, you can't.
You've probably got all of
this stuff already, anyway.
So if you don't work for
any of those organizations
then you are welcome
to have a go,
and hopefully we'll have
the URL up in a second.
OK, great.
Is this working?
Hurray.
So I'll start with
some thank-yous.
These are the people you
have to thank for today.
I curated the event.
[APPLAUSE]
Ruth Yarnit, who's actually
gone ahead to Akamai make sure
that the party is set up for
us, has been doing all the event
management, which is
why this edition of edge
is significantly less
shambolic than the last one.
And we have various
to thank it--
Adobe and Google
and [INAUDIBLE].
So onto the prizes.
This is the URL, so if you feel
eligible to win some prizes
this evening then tap
that URL into your phone.
And anyone on my
list who's not here
forfeits that prize to you.
We applied a highly
scientific methodology
involving how many times
you spoke, using Onslyde,
and also how many times you
were retweeted by the Edge Conf
Twitter account.
So based on that, the
winner-- just by a hair--
is Patrick Kavanagh.
Patrick, you win an
Adobe-- what is it called?
[LAUGHTER]
Adobe Creative Cloud
subscription for one year.
So go and see my
colleague Alberta
and he'll sort
you out with that.
Sorry, I'm blanking
on the stuff.
So we also have five
Google Chromecasts,
so if you're in the room-- Mark
[INAUDIBLE] congratulations.
Aide Edwards from EFT.
I know you're here.
We're not exempt,
so that's fine.
[LAUGHTER]
We didn't provide any of
the prizes, so that's fine.
Sarah Frost, congratulations.
Wow, everyone's here.
That's really cool.
Adam Singer.
Adam's here, as well.
Awesome.
Congratulations, Adam.
And Charles Kobe-Brant.
Are you here?
You are.
Congratulations.
So you all won
Google Chromecasts.
We also have Android TVs.
So [INAUDIBLE] TVs.
We have Jack Morgan.
Congratulations, Jack.
Jonathan Porter.
Oh, OK.
Jonathan's not here.
Jonathan, are you
sure you're not here?
No, he's not here.
OK, cool.
Wesley, do you want
to roll the dice?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
If you want a prize,
open your phone.
ANDREW BETTS: Sorry, you
have to have your phone open
on this address right now if
you want to win this prize.
OK?
MALE SPEAKER: All
right, here we go.
First one.
Your phone should be red.
And it'll be yellow if you win.
Anyone has a yellow phone?
ANDREW BETTS: Anyone
has a yellow phone?
MALE SPEAKER: Do we have one?
ANDREW BETTS: I
don't see a winner.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, no yellow.
Let's do it again.
Here we go.
Keep it open.
Oh, [INAUDIBLE] won
that one, again.
ANDREW BETTS: [INAUDIBLE]
win two things.
MALE SPEAKER: So we should
have another yellow phone now.
There it is, right there.
Random winner.
ANDREW BETTS: Hurray, finally.
MALE SPEAKER: How many
more should I do, Andrew?
ANDREW BETTS: I think we're
out of Android TVs, right?
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
We'll do a couple
more, just in case.
ANDREW BETTS: Alberto,
are we out of-- OK, cool.
MALE SPEAKER: Now
we're at Chromecast.
ANDREW BETTS: OK, so the next
we have Larry [INAUDIBLE].
Larry.
Congratulations.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
He's Adobe employee.
ANDREW BETTS: Oh, you're
an Adobe employee.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I didn't have
that on my list.
I did scratch out,
but I missed one.
Sorry.
Lukas [INAUDIBLE].
OK, we don't have a
Lukas [INAUDIBLE],
so let's roll the dice.
MALE SPEAKER: Roll the dice.
Here we go.
And the lucky
winner is-- aw, man,
don't change the styling
to get a yellow screen.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, who has the
yellow screen, besides Luke?
ANDREW BETTS: Did you just
open many, many, many tabs?
MALE SPEAKER: Here
it is, right here.
David.
ANDREW BETTS: David's won.
MALE SPEAKER: Are Mozillans
allowed-- Mozillians?
ANDREW BETTS: I believe
Mozillans are allowed.
I didn't hear
Mozillans were expempt.
MALE SPEAKER: Do
we need another?
ANDREW BETTS: That's it.
We're out of prizes.
Excellent.
Hooray.
So yeah, we like to award people
for contributing to the event,
so that's kind of nice.
OK, so onto-- could someone
push space on my computer?
Oh, OK.
Great.
So onto the finances
for the event today.
So one of the things we
do at EDGE Conf, which
is quite unique, is to tell you
what we spent all the money on
and where we made all our money.
We made about $40,000.
We have Google, very
largely, to thank
for a lot of that
sponsorship, along with Shape
and [INAUDIBLE] Logic
and Adobe and Akamai.
And we spent about
$27,000, which
means that we have $12,453
to donate to Hack the Hood.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm pleased to say we
have Susan Mernit from Hack
the Hood who will just tell us a
little bit about Hack the Hood,
but we've got a quick video
to show you, first of all.
Press play.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Welcome to our
graduation celebration.
We are excited to
have you here tonight
to celebrate the
last week of Hack
the Hood's summer bootcamp.
-Without getting too
personal about my life,
you know what I'm
saying-- I didn't grow up
with a lot of opportunities.
Young kid from the streets,
you know what I'm saying?
I got a lot of fears and worries
for my kids as they grow up.
My name is Charles Ray Jones
Jr, father of Charles Ray Jones
III, graduate of Hack the Hood.
Not only is he gaining
the skills necessary,
but he's meeting people
who could guide him
along the path he
choose to go on.
Not only information, not
only knowledge, but access.
-Hello, everybody, my
name is [INAUDIBLE].
I created websites for small
local businesses in Oakland.
My experience was wonderful.
It was something
that I love to do,
because I love the people
that I worked with,
and they were so
helpful in every aspect.
-One of our mentors, she
assigned us our clients
and we would call them, ask
them if they wanted a website.
We were able to convince them.
-I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm here to present my websites
that I built for clients.
I'm actually doing this to
get a feel for web designing,
because I want to
either do video game
design, mechanical
engineering, or voice actor.
So I'm trying to get a
feel for each of those
and see which one I like most.
Technology is something
that is going to be vital,
and it is for me.
If more youth are
involved, they will
be able to build
websites and also
get into the tech industries by
creating personal connections
with people that are already
working in the tech industry.
-My name is Erik and I'm a
mentor with Hack the Hood.
It's a lot of fun.
I would definitely
continue to do this.
Just seeing the
change in Mohammed
from when we started to the
end of the program, the things
that he learned.
He did three websites
for local businesses,
as well as his
own personal page.
I would love to see
this grow and mature
and expand into other cities.
I think it would be very
exciting to be a part of that.
They're no longer
just passive consumers
of what's going on
in the Internet.
0 actively involved
in contributing
to what the internet
is as a whole,
and I think that's
very empowering.
And I think it's just going to
change the face of the internet
as the youth get more
and more involved.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
-[INAUDIBLE].
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ANDREW BETTS: So, Susan Mernit,
founder of Hack the Hood.
SUSAN MERNIT: First of all,
thank you guys so much.
This is such a
wonderful thing to be
a recipient of this funding
from the Edge Conference,
and to have the Financial
Times and Andrew think of us.
So I just want to
thank everybody
for putting the money
for this conference
to such a good cause.
I want to just talk a
little bit about Hack
the Hood for a minute.
I spent eight years working
as an executive and a product
developer in Silicon Valley,
and then I moved to Oakland
because it was kind
of like Brooklyn,
where I had lived
for many years.
And what we discovered was that
so many people who actually
lived in Oakland felt so shut
out of the technology that
was happening 30 miles
away in the Valley,
eight miles away
in San Francisco,
and coming to Oakland.
And as much as everybody was
on their phone-- consuming
technology, doing
gaming, doing messaging,
doing e-commerce--
they had no idea
that they could
really be consumers.
And people were like,
"Gee, getting a job at UPS
would be like a fantastic job.
It has a lot of security."
So we started Hack
the Hood because we
wanted to grow a generation of
programmers and people working
in other jobs in tech who
really were not shut out,
who could be young people of
color from very low income
families.
So the kids that you saw on the
screen from our summer program
in Oakland all
came from families
that literally made less
than $18,000 a year.
They were kids who started
out not doing any programming.
Really avid users of
tech on their phone.
And by the end of the
course, they not only all
were doing web
development using weebly,
but they were learning CSS,
HTML, starting to look at PHP.
Here we are at the
end of the summer
and we have kids who are
going to be taking classes
in computer science, kids you're
going to start doing Android
development in a workshop
with us with codepath.org.
We were able to take people
who see themselves as very
isolated, very shut out, very
not able to work in tech--
they wouldn't fit in-- and
light a fire of hope that's
really connected to building
relationships by meeting
people, working in the field,
having mentors, visiting
tech companies.
And they're really starting
to understand, "Well, what
kind of skills do I have to
learn to actually do this?"
So we've done two
summers in Oakland
and we just got a
grant from Google
to expand into five
cities in the Bay Area.
So we're trying to
scale up, and this money
will be super helpful to
help us by Chromebooks
and other kinds of equipment,
and to pay instructors
as we expand--
because we'll be going
into other communities
like Oakland,
where there may not be funding
to actually start next summer.
I would love to invite
all of you guys--
if you live in the area,
or you're in the Bay Area
or you're interested in
volunteering, being a mentor,
helping out.
We'll be on the peninsula.
We hope to be in San Francisco
to get in touch with me.
It's susan@hackthehood.org.
It's on the Hack
the Hood website,
and we're actively looking
to grow our program.
It could be anything from an
afternoon to a six week stint
a couple of hours a week.
But if you've thought
about giving back
and you kind of want to grow
more people in your own image,
we have some very, very
smart young people.
But they really
need relationships
and they relating opportunities.
So thank you so much
for this opportunity.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW BETTS: Thanks, Susan.
OK, it's just left to tell
you how to get to the party.
But before I do, someone
left this-- which is a-- aha.
There you go.
That's easy.
Do you know what it is, yet,
or do you just fancy something?
OK, I believe you.
OK, so I think all we have left
is here's how to get to Akamai.
The directions are
also on the hub,
so if you want to go
to edgeconf.com/hub,
there's a link
there to directions.
It's about a 30-minute
walk, or you can take a cab.
And we'll see you there.
Oh, and you need
to take your pass.
If you don't have your
lanyard, you won't get in.
See you there.